now this was a scene you likely did not
see on one of your local or national
newscasts the white house announcing a
bold plan to change the lives in America
of some of our poorest citizens those
who live in the most distressed and
sometimes the most dangerous
neighborhoods flanked by senator Tim
Scott and Beatty founder Bob Johnson
with Van Jones looking on you see him
there the President signed an executive
order creating something called the
opportunity and revitalization Council
now if you think this is just kind of
another brick in the bureaucracy here in
DC signifying nothing
think again led by HUD secretary ben
Carson it will coordinate efforts across
the entire federal government to deliver
jobs investment and growth in
underprivileged areas by the way
includes rural areas too now this means
more private sector money will flow into
some of these high-risk areas or low
development areas and what will that do
in turn that will deliver jobs
[Applause]
of course you heard that the few
reporters were actually on hand there
they weren't interested in the substance
of this undertaking all they were
interested in is shouting questions out
about Cohen an unlike most White House
events starring Trump it was not
broadcast on cable or on c-span or any
of the network's huh I wonder why I'll
tell you why
because Trump is delivering results for
those who Democrats thought that they
had forever co-opted politically it's
all kind of you know smashes the presses
relentless drumbeat about how the
president just doesn't like black people
what more do we need to see you hear
from this racist man here we have a
president who has once again he said
racist and despicable words about
african-americans people of color all
the policy that he's put forward has
been anti people of color he has
continued policies that I believe are
racist in nature the President of the
United States is racist all of us
already knew that the president seems to
harbor racist feelings about people of
color it's just despicable every time I
watch so I'm like I don't want to play
them anymore
media mogul Bob Johnson one of the most
prominent and most successful
african-americans probably on the planet
obviously beg to disagree with that
montage he was on hand to recognize the
administration's drive and commitment to
help low-income Americans just recently
your Department of Labor signed a
historic document that created something
called Auto portability Auto portability
is designed to reduce retirement leakage
among low-income 401k account holders
who tend to cash out
mr. president you should know this 60%
of african-american Hispanic Americans
cash out of their 401k account this
program will put close to 800 billion
dollars back in the retirement pockets
of minority Americans so I just want to
applaud you better got no coverage I had
to play that just because no one saw it
now you see there are a lot of
politicians out there though who traffic
in bromides shining with the veneer of
real compassion hope is the insistence
that no matter how tough our
circumstances there are better days
ahead if we persist despite all of our
individual failings and all of our
inadequacies together we can overcome oh
that's nice I guess that's a Nobel Prize
material but the problem is talking
about hope it's beautiful but it won't
bring business into your community
people who can get jobs tend to have
more hope despair and crime in places
like Chicago and Baltimore spiraled out
of control during much of Obama's eight
years but I know you're gonna say but
Laura Obama and the Democrats care more
than Donald Trump look and you can see
it you can feel it they care then
they're gonna bring up Charlottesville
and the s whole comment that Trump made
to then drive their points home okay
even if for the sake of argument I
concede those points may the tonality
the wording maybe wouldn't have done
that way fine but I asked the following
who cares more about America and
particularly the working poor the guy
who delivers results record low
unemployment Opportunity Zones and
decent chance for criminal justice
reform or a party that is all talk and
no action I'll take the former any day
oh and by the way the press did find one
angle on the opportunity's own that they
well they thought this part of the
stories was worth covering
Jarrid and Trump himself are only
pushing these inner-city investment
incentives because they'll make money
off they're only their own real estate
holdings please secretary ben Carson
came on my radio show yesterday and he
swatted this whole thing away the zones
were picked by the governors they were
not picked by Derrick Krishna there are
all kinds of people in the country who
already have real estate in those zones
will they benefit probably why shouldn't
they benefit why shouldn't everybody
benefit you know why shouldn't we create
win-win situations I want to see more of
Ben Carson out there by the way I loved
what he had to say and once again the
media proves itself to be absolutely
incapable of covering virtually anything
about the work the President does to try
to restore our country not even a
inkling of objectivity and not he didn't
do this by the way to benefit just a few
of his pals or the people who voted for
him but he's doing this to try to
benefit those who have been served so
poorly by politicians of both parties
for decades but I'm telling you despite
everything that's swirling around him
the Democrats obsession with impeachment
the indictments etc etc the president
continues to do work that other
presidents wouldn't do and poor
working-class Americans will be better
for it
and that's the angle